maria nach osten ist leiterin des neuen
münchner polizei dezernats für
verbrechen die noch gar nicht
stattgefunden haben von außen nennen sie
nicht altmodisch aber muss nicht
eigentlich eine konkrete gefahr muss ich
eine konkrete gefahren drohen bevor die
polizei eingreifen
ja herr welke das können wir gerne
weiter zu machen aber dann verwandelt
sich heute ganz deutschland waren in
nordrhein-westfalen
ja das heißt ich gehe drei minuten mit
dem wut raus und wenn ich zurückkommen
haben die bulgaren schon mein haus
geklaut und den hund den sie das volk
meine meinung blöd ist ungeheuer gegen
grundrechte wie sagte einst der wohl
größte kleine innenminister den wir je
hatten
sicherheit ist ein super grundrecht so
sicherheit ist das zuerst grundrecht von
allen
deswegen machen wir in bayern jetzt
macht aus der konkreten gefahr die
drohende gefahr
um schon gehts ja dann können wir
telefonüberwachung post öffnen und fürs
internet heißt es rot zapft is
[Applaus]
ja
wo die auch angezapft werden oder was
ist ja was ist denn da los in bayern bei
euch hab ich gelesen dürfen gefährder
also leute die noch gar keine straftat
begangen haben quasi unbegrenzt in
präventivhaft genommen werden und das
gilt ausdrücklich nicht nur für
terroristen sondern seit letztem jahr
auch für normale kriminalität ok ich
sage mal so herr welke 1 dennis mitchell
wer in bayern nicht so leicht aus dem
knast gekommen
ja also ich finde erdogan wird im alter
ja langsam echt zu weit
deswegen wir sind stolz auf unser neues
polizeigesetz
man muss sich klar sein darüber dass
damit die größte und umfassendste
kontroll kompetenz geschaffen worden ist
für an der polizei in deutschland seit
1945 hat das beste gesetz seit 45
wer hat denn der regiert in bayern 45
was sie glaubt das war auch schon die
csu ja jedenfalls dieses famose gesetz
macht aus der bayerischen polizei de
facto reinigen nachrichtendienst wenn
ich entscheide bei ihnen droht gefahr
einfach weil mir nicht gefällt ist dass
radsatz online durchsuchung und ein
bewegungsprofil aufgrund ihrer
handydaten wobei wenn ich sie mir jetzt
so anschauen werden sie sich nicht
bewegen gelb in ihrem tollen neuen
gesetz steht bayerische polizisten
bayerische polizisten dürfen in
ausnahmefällen demnächst handgranaten
dabei haben die handgranate was keine
ahnung für alles möglichkeit ja wenn zum
beispiel einer in der feuerwehr zufahrt
parken man hat keine zeit auf den
abschleppdienst zu warten
[Applaus]
das ist
das ist total praktisch das ist total
praktisch so er sonst noch irgendwelche
anmerken zum neuen polizeigesetz
ich find's super machen ja eine
hausmauer und herüber
[Applaus]